For as long as humans
have looked at the stars,
we have wondered how
they got there -
and what lies beyond them.
Scientists have long searched
for a simple theory
that explains how
the universe works,
a theory of everything.
Many theories have been tested
and so far, every one of them
has failed to fully explain
what we see in our universe.
But there is one
particularly enticing idea
that some theoretical physicists
think might just be ‘it’,
String Theory.
String theory is finite.
It doesn't blow up.
It doesn't collapse on itself.
That's why we believe in it.
Other theories do collapse.
Other theories do blow up.
But string theory does not.
Dr Michio Kaku has spent decades
grappling with -
and attempting to answer -
some of life’s biggest questions.
What happened before the Big Bang?
Are there other universes?
What lies on the other side
of creation?
The other side of a black hole?
Are gateways possible?
Wormholes? Higher dimensions?
Do we live in a multiverse?
All these questions
cannot be answered
using our present-day understanding.
When Dr Kaku talks about our
present-day understanding,
he means our current best theories
about the way the universe works.
In truth, they contradict each other.
And sometimes even
give conflicting results -
Albert Einstein’s general theory
of relativity works perfectly well
for predictions about the
movements of stars and galaxies,
but doesn’t work when applied to the
behaviour of subatomic particles.
Conversely, quantum theory is great
with atoms
but predicts the whole universe
should collapse into a black hole,
which it clearly doesn't
because we’re all still here!
So, will we ever find a single
theory that explains everything?
Two thousand years ago, Pythagoras
asked himself that question.
The great Greek mathematician
said that there must
be a unifying principle,
a paradigm by which to summarise
the vast creation
that we see all around us
of the universe that we know.
And he looked around
and saw a lyra string.
You pluck a lyra string and
you get a note,
you pluck another one,
you get another note.
And then he said, aha, the
mathematics of music is rich enough
to explain the diversity of
everything we see around us.
And only recently have we
come up with a new idea
based on the Pythagorean
idea of music.
In other words, string theory.
So how do we go from Pythagoras’
musical musings to proper physics?
The first port of call would be a
particle accelerator
like the Large Hadron Collider
at CERN in Switzerland,
where tiny particles are smashed
to pieces in high energy collisions
and then closely studied.
These experiments are our
best way of testing theories
about how the universe works.
So what does string theory
predict we would see?
We now believe that all these
subatomic particles,
hundreds of subatomic particles
that we get by smashing protons
at the Large Hadron Collider,
they're nothing but musical notes
as Pythagoras believed.
If I had a super microscope
and I could peer into an electron,
what would I see?
I would see a rubber band,
a vibrating rubber band.
Of course, Dr Kaku doesn’t mean
an actual rubber band.
But rather something
rubber-band-like.
Or to put it another way -
the strings in string theory.
And just like the strings
on a musical instrument,
if you put some energy
into them, they vibrate.
It vibrates one way,
we call it an electron.
We vibrate it another way,
it's called a neutrino.
it's called a quark.
But it's the same rubber band.
So, string theory offers
a tantalising possibility -
an explanation for the vast variety
we see in the universe,
from the collisions of stars
to the collisions of atoms.
Of course, string theory is just that
- a theory.
Its critics point out that many of
its predictions are untestable -
something Dr Kaku himself
acknowledges.
Its proponents though,
consider it to be
the best hope of unifying physics.
Dr Kaku believes string theory
could even explain
the mystery that is dark matter.
Dark matter makes up most
of the matter of the universe.
It is invisible and it holds
the galaxies together,
but how do we prove it?
We think that dark matter could be
the next octave of the string.
If you could magnify all the
particles you see around us,
we would see a lot of rubber bands,
a lot of rubber bands
vibrating at different frequencies.
But the rubber band
has higher octaves.
That, we think, is dark matter.
If Dr Kaku is right, the huge
complexity of the entire universe
could be reduced to the simple
and elegant vibration of strings.
I think the one thing
that people should realise
is that physics,
at the fundamental level,
gets simpler and simpler
the deeper we go,
but becomes more powerful,
the deeper we go.
The universe is simpler
than we thought.